foreign
[Music]
there's a very easy way of being a
skeptic about anything and you find it
in philosophy throughout history which
is that you define the thing you want to
be skeptical about in a way that makes
it impossible for it to be achieved and
then you celebrate the fact that it
doesn't exist and this happens with like
free free will the self and it happens
with objectivity and it's not a complete
straw man there is a certain notion of
objectivity which is that to be
objectively true it must be true in such
a way that it has nothing at all to do
it's completely independent of any kind
of perspective it's like the God's eye
view and you know to be fair you know
Plato arguably did argue that perfect
knowledge should be of that kind he also
argued that no one had it of course
um so even he was acknowledging that it
didn't exist before he thought maybe we
could get there
um but that's kind of how could there be
I mean Hillary talks about the
perspective or nature of knowledge
and of course there's no way human
knowledge can ever completely escape
from the limitations of our perspectives
but does that mean there's no sense in
objectivity I don't think so and I'll
I'll refer to someone a better
philosopher than myself Thomas Nagel in
his book The View from nowhere the view
from nowhere is of course an ironic
title there is no view from nowhere
every view is from somewhere
perspectival nature of knowledge again
but Nagel says look subjective and
objective are not these opposites
they're kind of Ideal points on a
spectrum and your understanding becomes
more objective the less it depends on
the particularities of your own
Viewpoint and that's why in things like
science you can get a very very high
degree of objectivity because the
equations of physics are true there
would be if if an alien could understand
those equations they wouldn't have to
have any of the same sense apparatus as
at all they would still be true where
certain truths I think again things like
race and identity they're not like that
they're not they they have a kind of
inherent sort of subjectivity they are
more part of our social structures and
our society and so forth so as long as
you sort of don't think that objective
means completely free from any kind of
hint of perspective it just means it's
kind of a direction to go towards we can
have truths which are more objective and
you kind of have to have that if you
give up on that idea you are left with
the Morris of of anything goes and and
leotard I just read this from leotard
actually it's very interesting he said
that even the Nobel Laureate biologist
Peter medoware believe that there is no
scientific method and that a scientist
is before anything else a person who
tells stories so far so anything goes
but he adds the only difference is that
he the scientist he note that is Duty
bound to verify them so leotard
recognizes that in the science in The
Sciences there is that need for
verification which means that your
claims have a I'd say a greater
objectivity now we've been nice and
baggy about that session of questions
um and we're going to shorten this an
expert at one a bit because in a way
it's kind of more observational and less
philosophical
um and it is about the question about
what the impact of post-modernism has
been there Jules you um reflected a
little bit on on that
um after hearing what you've heard would
you stick to the notion that
post-modernist Concepts as they have
been utilized
um have been damaging I I came across
um because we've all had to kind of look
at this stuff a 1999 uh rejection of
Julius Butler by Martha Nussbaum which
in a way was kind of pointed forward to
what it was that was gonna that she
thought might happen and I have a
suspicion that you would think that it
has happened
yes and it's interesting I was reading
that paper recently
I think it's
the professor of parody is that right
um and yes I mean I think it's had a
terribly damaging effect
on the academy which then of course
bleeds out into wider society and and
pre-post modernism
um you know our University's feminism
um was kind of taken over to use an
aggressive word by feminist philosophers
and feminist sociologists were pushed
out of the you know equation which means
that applied knowledge so the knowledge
that was previously
um disseminated by those feminists that
were also activists got things done
wanted their research to have an
influence on law policy Society in
general
um became I think really dominated by
more abstract thought and of course
there are specific
um
respect to Judith Butler's work that has
led to a highly problematic Erasure of
the political category of women because
if you like me recognize that women are
a sex class and Men of course are a sex
class to to a rage Woman as a category
means that we can't actually achieve
solidarity between women and we're
constantly looking at individual
identities as though they somehow count
for a structural oppression so one brief
example
asexuality polyamory right in what way
have asexuals or people in polyamorous
relationships lost their housing their
families all been beaten up on the
street because of that individual
identity and so that I think is one of
the results of it's like identity
politics but without the politics I mean
how do you react to that
um
one of the things that comes to mind is
how this question of
you know obviously we need
the feminism needs some idea of woman as
a category Woman as a group to to have
to not lose it to dry
um but at the same time I think there
can also be there's also room within
feminism to to complicate that category
I mean woman is I think that the term
woman is in many ways a male invention a
male project I mean Simone de bevoir
says that some something to that as well
um and so we need to make space for
those conversations and I guess that
might be one of the contributions that
Judith Butler in her I mean she's kind
of as obscure maybe as postmodernism is
you know everybody speaks about Judith
Butler's theories but we don't get it
partly because she writes in such an
obscure way
um but I wonder if that conversation
kind of is feminism you know this this
engagement with what it is to be a woman
is it a construct is it not
um and you know as Hillary was saying
this is a conversation or was saying in
terms of post-modernism and language I
think this woman questioned within
feminism is what has been there from the
very beginning you know when some women
were fighting for suffrage you had
others debating no that's not what women
do and it's kind of always been about
complicating that category so yeah uh
Hillary we could consume conceivably be
talking about other damaging schools of
philosophy I don't know I don't know
whether there's a big where there's a
balloon debate about somewhere about
which ones you ditch and which ones you
wouldn't and so on but we're talking
about this one
um insofar as it has as it has been
influential in the political and wider
sphere do you think it's been beneficial
or not
as I said at the beginning I think there
are lots of aspects of the way that post
Martin applied which are problematic and
which would they be which sorry which
would they be well where where it it
looks as if you can simply assert a view
in the light of your particular uh
perspective or View and so that is
sufficient it's sufficient that
um uh that you have had this experience
you've had this uh understanding of
things and that's enough
um and I think that's a misunderstanding
I I you know of course the key thing
that's going on here in our conversation
is that I think the notion of Truth is
theological that is I think that the
very idea of Truth is uh it functions in
the same way as God for a for a
scientific world it's something that we
reach towards but we can't get get at
and I do think it is problematic and and
and so you only have to look lots of
different people who want to assert
objective truth
um uh but they don't agree on their
objective truths they have radically
different views I mean uh Pope Benedict
is a is a deep critic of objective Truth
uh Liz truss is a is a deep tricket of
postmodernism I doubt whether she has
much in common with Julia's view of the
world
um and that's the first indication that
there's something amiss here that the
people who are most assertive of
objective truth they don't agree and
they don't agree on what their objective
truths are and that points I think to
what is going on underneath the surface
is that the desire to say it is just
true is a desire to just say I'm right
I've got it right and there isn't an
alternative and that's and to draw a
close to that conversation and I don't
think we can ever do that but that
doesn't mean to say we don't give up on
the key vital bits of the Enlightenment
which were observation watching to see
what the consequences of your account of
the world is and reason looking to see
oh but that bit doesn't fit with this
bit that doesn't if you hold that view
you've got to hold this view that's what
we have to double down on we have to
double down on those key things
especially in a situation where we we've
given up on a theological Truth uh
thanks very much we're type of time on
this one Julian before we come on to the
kind of what next uh explosion that
we're going
once I wanted to ask you this forever
and forgive me should glucofu go oh very
good I like that well the problem with
this postman has been the dock is a
title it isn't post-modernism I mean
food code never identified as a
post-modernist neither did
are I mean the the term is used so
loosely it's become sort of almost
ridiculous that what I think people have
identified as a problem is a certain
kind of way in which ideas are filtered
down and got current common currency and
have various different sources and it's
basically the idea that there are there
is nothing but Stories We Tell nothing
but the narratives we create ourselves
that's been the real problem and that
does lead to this kind of thing if I
feel it it's true thing just brilliantly
parodied in The Simpsons an episode
where Homer Simpson is accused of sexual
harassment and somebody is interviewing
a witness and she says I've never seen
Homer Simpson I don't know Homer Simpson
I'm sorry I can't go on and the
presenter says that's okay your tears
say far more than any facts could ever
do you know
um and that kind of like primusive my
experience cause if there's if there's
only stories if they're only narratives
and there's nothing
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas